[Applause]
but first up he is the u.s congressman
who represents california's 28th
district
the chairman of the house intelligence
committee adam schiff ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
congressman how you doing
thank you very much appreciate it we're
we're
you're satisfied that we are safe here
yes you're about a mile away from me
okay all right and the audience
just want you to know all right so uh in
the debate mike pence
just like his boss really would not
commit to a
peaceful transfer of power i've asked
you this question on the show before
um and you have a bill now i think the
democrats
you know getting the message here and
it's called the protecting our democracy
act is that right
what is that it is uh you know after
watergate congress passed a whole
package of reforms to try to address
all the institutional breakdowns we've
done the same thing working with the
speaker and my fellow chairs
we have measures in the package that
protect against the abuse of the pardon
power that
allow for the expedited enforcement of
congressional subpoenas
that protect whistleblowers that protect
inspector generals that allow us to
enforce the emoluments
clause when a president like this one
enriches himself in the oval office
and a whole host of other reforms so we
told the statute of limitations so
prosecution of the president could go
forward and not uh
be hampered by the fact that a president
can outweigh the the statute
so these are
i don't expect i don't expect bill that
the republicans
this year are going to support this next
year if we're fortunate
and have a biden presidency i think
they'll support these reforms
because they're not going to want
they're not going to want a democratic
president to do
anything they allow donald trump to do
this senator mike lee
says his is his quote this week we're
not a democracy
democracy isn't the objective liberty
peace and prosperity are
that's i mean i kind of know what he
means he went on to say ranked democracy
can
thwart that the founding fathers were
afraid of direct democracy
that is true but for a senator say we're
not a democracy it's not the objective
that's pretty dangerous talk especially
at this moment with this president
absolutely absolutely and uh
it's all the more astonishing because we
see around the world
a real challenge to democracy we see
rise of autocracy obviously in russia
we see totalitarianism in china but we
see
in egypt and turkey with erdogan and the
philippines with duterte
in brazil all over the world a rise of
autocrats challenging the very idea of
democracy
so to have republican senators say yeah
you know ranked democracy isn't such a
good thing
that's music to putin's ears i'm sure
but in terms of
the attacks on our own institutions the
president too as you say
won't commit even to peacefully leaving
the oval office
if and when he loses those kind of
comments are just dangerous
so but
but our system i mean i've been talking
about how the u.s constitution needs a
page one rewrite for a very long time
this is a tough sell in a lot of america
uh
who believed that the constitution was
literally delivered by
jesus do we have that picture of that
painting this is a
this is what a lot of people think
and i was reminded of this when uh rbg
died recently because she quote was
quoted in 2012 by saying
i would not look to the us constitution
if i were drafting a constitution
in the year 2012. and she went on to
mention south africa has a better one
canada because they were written more
recently
the european convention on human rights
she said was better it's very hard to
get a politician to
talk about the constitution how it needs
fundamental change but the electoral
college i could go on
maybe you will be that politician who
will say
the constitution they were great back
then but they
they were not nostradamus they couldn't
see a lot of [ __ ] that was going to
happen
where were you on that issue of the
constitution
well you know i certainly agree with
ruth bader ginsburg in terms of
if we were starting over we would
obviously make sure that
everyone could vote we wouldn't
discriminate against women
of people of color we would not
[Applause]
have to amend and correct for all the
mistakes of the original
but but bill let me ask you this who
would you trust
to draft a new constitution mike lee no
mitch mcconnell any of those jokers
i certainly wouldn't uh and and this is
the
this is the problem um i i don't
i don't have any confidence frankly that
we could improve upon
the word the work product of the framers
with the crowd we have today
so i like it in theory
but i think we are better off focusing
on discrete amendments to the
constitution to
overturn citizens united and make sure
that we can uh have
elections untampered or uninfluenced by
excessive
expenditures and dark money uh and i
would favor doing away with the
electoral college system which i think
is
yeah i mean that's deflated
right so if if there's a new supreme
court justice a lot of people are saying
that roe versus wade will be
overturned um but
for a lot of the country it's already
been overturned
a lot of places in america you just you
know you can't get an abortion then they
have to drive to another state
why hasn't congress passed a law
because the courts of course just rule
on laws but
why isn't there a roe versus amendment
law that you guys have done
i think there should be i think you
should
take up a roe v wade enforcement actor
protection act
but i do think also we need to be
mindful of the limitations of a statute
if the president is successful in
further stacking the supreme court
that court would likely overturn any law
congress passes
to protect a woman's right to choose so
we should try
and we should hope that we're successful
in uh and thwarting
another uh right-wing uh justice that
would
overturn roe v wade that would take away
people's health care strike down the
affordable care act
but uh but i think we need to be
realistic about how far
a law can go when the supreme court is
held bent on overturning it
you